hello and welcome my name is Jake I'm
here with Joey and we're gonna do some
Far Cry 5 arcade
this is arcade heroes basically puts you
in random arcade levels that people have
made I like to call it arcade roulette
because you don't really know what
you're gonna get
yeah some are good most of them are
probably going to be bad so we'll do a
couple of these first and then we'll try
to go through the arcade and pick out
some of the actual good ones here yeah
we found a couple good ones the game
hasn't been out for that long so and
these maps take a while so we're not
expecting amazing things yeah but so
this is what like Dave this is day 2 and
thing is with with Arcade Mode
there are just a lot of different assets
that people can use in order to make
whatever levels they want I know that
there's you know a couple different
mission types as well there's like
assault journey where you just try to
make from point A to point B you can
make your own outpost that you can
liberate and kind of design different
things go in there so this is a problem
so first of all no texture on this okay
which is brought but the actual problem
is that it expects us to kill eighty
three people do we have any weapons we
have no weapons what I'm not entirely
sure all right well well these guys have
just been just set up a little picnic
for us here
no one has guns they run okay well I'll
go to this town we're not gonna kill all
83 cuz that is a big take a long time
here yeah little wolf be considered one
of the enemies and find out throwing
away oh well well let it run we'll let
it run oh my gosh they made this as big
as possible to no vehicle you can spawn
vehicles right or I mean you can put
them into the yeah I mean I can't now
cuz I'm playing someone else's map but
when I make a map yes I can spawn
vehicles or if I want I could download
this map and I could add vehicles and
then republish it they'll still get
credit for making the map but I'll get
like credit for a revision yeah
uh nice little cozy town here that won't
still [ __ ] me stupid wolf I feel ya oh
my god no guy wasn't even important he
was right one of the enemies so there's
no gun you got a mortar though oh here
we go
can I just so you guys just find where
they all are situated and that looks
like a guy doesn't it no I have a
feeling we need to trigger something
yeah maybe
all right next map what was this one
called it had no name it was like a
bunch of squares so there's the
character this woman expects us to kill
87 instead of 83 see this is the problem
my pet peeves on these maps I've played
quite a few so far my pet peeves when
they're all flat this one check yeah all
flat that is bad and then the other
thing I don't like is when it asked me
to kill 87 people in Europe Union what
makes a good man I know we're like a
couple days in but what when your
opinion would make like a good map to
play so before I answer I'm gonna
preface in saying that I'm not very good
at making maps I mean like I don't think
if I had the time I think I could
probably make something kind of cool but
what I will say is if you want to make a
map for the love of God don't make it
flat
don't make it too big make it make it a
size that makes sense and then make the
objective reasonable because no one's
gonna want to kill 87 people you just
killed her and her twin I know and then
add some texture to
okay we're gonna we're gonna end my life
early then so this is like typically
what happens you get a lot of like naps
that are very good but occasionally
you'll get one that's really good and
that is why I keep doing this it's it's
kind of addicting it'll yeah so even if
you don't win you don't finish it you
still get this yeah at least I'm doing
random ones I get time to experience so
I get extra experience we're gonna
dislike that one I'm sorry
anything above one star is it's pretty
good it's a good sign is a good sign in
this that at least one person has made
it like has liked it yeah okay a little
bit better we got one got 17 to kill
instead of 87 it's a little bit more
doable
silent takedown here get up on the barn
maybe oh geez
who is this guy Mollie see me
I think there's someone behind me the
sound okay we're alright turn to bill
well sometimes I hear that kind of stuff
oh god a grenade
alright that was all right yeah that was
all right this type right here is a
journey so that means I'm not actually I
don't need to kill anyone I need to just
get to the end I have no weapons there
are a lot of little markers here Oh a
gun I'll take the gun yeah so that is
one thing it's to no fault of the makers
it's something with the engine so you
can put objective markers the only thing
is is that they all spawn at the same
time and like if you get to one it
doesn't disappear so it's kind of messy
actually I should probably say TV so far
looking pretty good this one's got the
atmosphere yeah that's another thing I
really like you can you can make like
really good atmosphere with yeah like
you can you can set the I remember seen
you guys doing it and you can sound like
the moon sighs and then sighs the light
yeah you can even add wind so all the
trees will sway and stuff like that
which looks really cool I'm surprised
it's in this to be honest it's already
gotten here yeah so every little object
as far as I know every little object
that you're seeing was in fact placed by
someone yes
no so like it for the most part like
there are some like houses that already
have a bunch of stuff in them already
and by that you can place trees with
like a little not not really a pattern
but some posh yeah have them like
staggered a little bit to make it look
more natural this is pretty well thought
out I have a sneaking suspicion that
this may be the Ubisoft maps that they
have I don't think so cuz I don't think
the this plays Ubisoft ones the Oh
doesn't Kade here oh no I don't think it
does plus when you see the UV saw
you know it's you be something like what
why it's just like it looks like it's
straight from the game no happen here oh
that's that's the other thing everyone
loves their yetis yeah like most the
time you know I forget yeah the thing is
you don't even need to worry about
killing things man
the strobe effect is not ideal a little
distracting
it is dark do we make it the choppa
there we go everybody scape
what do you think what do you think of
that one I thought was whoa that's a
good amount of experience that was
pretty good but I feel like it's still a
lot of just you know point A to point B
and so skip rating I was also like just
because compared to the other ones yeah
we we disliked and then refrain from
voting I think this one deserves alike
so we have one left that was our fourth
one okay do our very last one let's see
if it's a dud or not one always got more
than a star look at that apocalypse base
miss spelt a no Inc is the one I'm gonna
do a salt all right
man we got trees in this building here
swaying back and forth okay we have 72
to kill 70 to see how far we get so
there was one I played it was it kind of
had that similar vibe as this except it
was much smaller and you're on an island
yeah and you had to fight like 70 of
these except instead it put the mountain
waves and it was like a zombie defense
yeah I think that's kind
I feel like that's the way to go with
these because if I were gonna do 70
people I think that's yeah I think
especially because the a lot of the maps
we're doing are so big you know yeah you
waste a lot of that time just going from
one place to another trying to look for
people all right we're gonna go to that
marker up there okay and we'll call it
and then we'll straight well we won't
call we'll switch over to the to the
maps that the curated maps I guess yeah
no not necessarily because they're
really good some of them are but like
just because some of them are funny -
yeah they're a little more themed than
this well you never know this one could
be interesting okay so we got a prison
here pretty sure the markers just
playing to the roof no all right I say
we I think we've seen enough of this one
okay here we are on my favorites we're
gonna start with hotline Miami so this
one's cool because it takes
what makes hotline Miami hotline Miami
puts it into a far cry game so basically
all the different mechanics that you
have Oh in the difficulty yes so uh will
do I don't know but none of these have
anything will do jet will do hard
because you don't start off with
anything right yeah but look so there's
a bat here that we take also one heard a
noise and it's like got like the
pulsating my god lights
oh you got you got you got bring that
bat out yeah you're right huh run around
me throw nice
oh you know what they need for this one
that would make it a little bit better I
feel like a time limit oh yeah like you
that way you have to rush them in yeah
that would that would be pretty cool all
right
we killed the kids at the exit sweet
that was pretty cool yeah it you could
tell it was kind of rushed and it must
have been because it came out pretty
much the day the game came yeah but I I
really enjoy that one yeah I like the
concept of bringing other games and then
sort of like cobbling together something
that's similar in theme oh we've got
here about the sea air but first okay
we're gonna do this one I really like
this one this is know we don't get
caught this one is more of a linear
level basically you're just killing
enemies but I think it's it's very it's
very like tightly designed there's a lot
of like cool little storytelling that
they did yeah like this one alright so
the legs returned true it's like alright
I was may have been in there survived
the crash I have a pistol though
everything is just on fire somewhere
okay so we got an outpost one so we'll
need to liberate it yeah without them
hitting the alarm dead and like it's
very claustrophobic yeah yeah this is
this is kind of like what I was hoping
for for everything is it may be a little
bit more linear but it's a lot more
focus yeah there's a lot more
interesting things to see you like right
in front of you instead of having to you
know go into the houses all the way
across the map and order yeah people to
kill
autumn all right no one's called uh I'm
gonna see if I can bust the see there's
the alarm
yeah there see if I bust it before
someone you get to cool all arms is able
to make our way back in
oh gosh you guys take a lot of shots
that you know
oh my god it's still alive come on
there we go all right
five more actually you know what burn
them all
oh no no Neil
flamethrowers dangerous there we go
we got one more left what was that does
that mountain there turn around a
volcano is that where you're in you're
like on the tropical island that one's
pretty cool I like that one
interesting interesting focused cool
design
yeah good very good um just like feel
like game feel and the atmosphere is
really nice
alright so we've got one more that we
picked out this is uh you probably saw
it when we went oh yeah this is the
legend of zeldo but I love that like
binoculars grapple you got a slingshot
that you got a Deku stick and a repair
torch yeah I remember that yeah yeah of
course
so we start off in the Kakariko village
what do you think this is cute for us go
forth wink oh is that the Deku Tree
edition tree Thank You forest
detach all right cool
and then here's Lon Lon ranch right here
and hop on one of my hop on opponent
wait which one's Epona um I feel like
it's got more of those yeah this one
your trusty steed right here Epona
alright sorry a pony you're gonna have
to wait here and oh god just like a link
just as I remember I like how they gave
them the green jacket - oh no that's
actually my jacket yours yeah oh I
loaded link doesn't like you got it I
got to use my hi-yah whoa a little bit
darker than you remember yeah I mean of
zeldo though oh I meant to throw that
that's a lot of like a little boomerang
right yeah exactly
alright so we killed the target however
we don't want to leave yet because
what's a Legend of Zelda dungeon without
a new item right right jirobo hi there
jirobo I felt like we don't even need
that with the slingshot though
especially if you can load arrows yeah
here we are
so this is the town square
Hyrule square these things are the what
are they called what are the zombies
called in Zelda Oh
let me go look them up yeah it'll come
to me too late I'm sure all right
here look this is this is the finale
battle gotta prepare ourselves for the
final the finale
alright you ready to see the light
arrows light arrows guns straight up
guns baby
and now here's Ganon be Ganon come on
oh god don't you remember the legend of
zelda
Oh No
my god I think you've done for
dum-dum-dum-dum and there we are
The Legend of Zelda zeldo zeldo remember
Zelda so when you get to the top of the
mountain there's a bear that you fight
in like a boss arena and he's when they
give you the
renée's I though I don't know how he
died um let's like it yeah I like that I
freeze although yeah for Zelda
alright so that's what we have for you
today if you guys enjoyed this let us
know we're hoping to do more of this
yeah if it catches on if people are
enjoying it we'd love to check out other
maps that people make and if you guys
have any recommendations feel free to
find us on Twitter and send them our way
but until next time thank you guys for
watching see ya